Today, and also at the time I was writing my dissertation, my main area of activity has been the study of discharge in insulating liquids
Insulating liquids are used mainly in high-voltage transformers
Obviously, in general, those transformers have liquid breakdowns.
Therefore, it is important to understand the discharges in order to understand the defects of these electrical apparatus
Mathematica was already being used when I arrived at the lab.
It was used by some researchers 15 or 20 years ago.
Since then, we used Mathematica more and more, to the point where it became our main tool.
We have experimental results that we are able to analyze very easily with Mathematica
and eventually compare them to theories or models.
The first two notebooks concern the discharge aspect in insulating liquids
I will need to explain (laughter).
We are trying to understand the application of electric fields, namely high electric fields, on insulating liquids
Mathematica is very interesting for analytical calculations
And then, I would say that my biggest interest in Mathematica
is to be able to marry both the analytical calculation and numerical computation in a single formulation of code
and be able to mix it all just to get possibly a confrontation model showing discrepancies in experimental and theoretical results.
And then the big advantage that makes things easier with Mathematica
is that from a number of data points we will be able to reconstruct
in fact, quite easily a continuous model from only a few points
since Mathematica has this ability to make functions from interpolations
So, you can simplify the problem that was initially difficult or had only a few points tabulated.
Somehow we can finally solve this continuous problem using this aspect of Mathematica.
The goal of the third notebook was to show that we were able to somehow develop an experiment.
The device we realized after this study--we used Mathematica in part of this study
is the realization of a calorimeter to measure the dielectric losses in the power of electronic components.
The calorimetric device we designed was precisely to measure
the quantity of heat emitted by the components of dielectric power.
Which was not necessarily possible with any other calorimetric techniques available today
Mathematica was used mainly for it, that is to say the device dimension
but also to find properties, good properties
and therefore the right materials that will allow us to make this device.
One of the many advantages of Mathematica is the Manipulate function
that allows you to see in real time the influence of parameters
in an extremely fast and very visual way. It is fantastic.